c'est plus qu'une gourde c'est une faute
audrey pulvar fait de la politique
candidate dans une élection importante
et elle devrait savoir que ces groupes
interdits aux blancs sont portés par des
gens qui ont clairement une idéologie
anti française anti universaliste
[Musique]
en fait tout commence je dirais dans les
années 80 avec sos racisme la gauche
abandonne finalement son modèle
traditionnel d'assimilation on est
fasciné par les états unis la gauche
converti à un modèle multiculturaliste
six axes son discours - sur
l'assimilation que sur le droit à la
différence
en parallèle il ya également un discours
très anti français à travers un livre
comme celui de bhl on est dans une
culture de la repentance qui explique
finalement qui réduit l'histoire de
france a vicié donc il ya ce double
mouvement à gauche et repentance et
droit à la différence et déjà à l'époque
certains observateurs alerte en 1993
paul yonnet le sociologue explique que
cette logique multiculturalisme et de
repentance ne peut que conduire à
réveiller le feu identité revient lui
aussi le tournant terra nova au moment
de l'élection de françois hollande où la
gauche stories le fait qu'elle doit
abandonner ses ambitions sociales
abandonné les classes populaires et
qu'elle doit s'adresser aux minorités
aux jeunes aux femmes et à rentrer dans
quelque chose qui est plus du tout est
né à sa liste qui est plus du tout
social mais qui ouvre une brèche pour
des politiques identitaires donc voilà
il ya ce discours-là qui monte dans une
partie de la gauche et ça audrey pulvar
ne saurait l'ignorer on est dans cette
situation très paradoxale où finalement
le l'antiracisme le nouvel anti racisme
a conduit à l'émergence d'un nouveau
racisme